[Music]
now for a night this important I think I
need to dress the part Bruce do you mind
[Applause]
[Music]
jealous ladies it's that quick and
simple now
Bruce gets the tux on me very quickly I
thought we should take a quick look
before the show starts and how Bruce
perfected the amazing art of the quick
tuxedo change when they told me I had to
put a tuxedo on him on air I was upset
because I don't like touching him Bruce
do you mind he's really cold to the
touch like a popsicle at first Scott
would tie me when I practice on a
mannequin when they first started I mean
Bruce was not very good at all I
practice every day there's always room
for improvement can you guys try these
on
sorry Bruce we're busy are you sure yes
we're sure get out here
I just think back to my days as a green
beret
and instead of slicing the neck of some
mercenary in the jungles of Borneo I'm
just putting a tux on a talk show host
[Applause]
[Music]
why did we make you dead at the end
stupidest thing I've ever seen 1964 haha
anyway look
[Laughter]